truth is the most important way that you
can maintain self-esteem is just telling
the truth the absence of secrets so we
always say you know like we're only as
sick as the secrets we keep it took me
so long
to take that adage seriously and I
cannot believe how it changed my life
that practice of telling someone your
deepest darkest secret telling someone I
just did cocaine 400 you know grams of
it last week or whatever and they still
hang out with you right yeah so you have
the data of like I can acknowledge all
these parts of myself and people won't
leave they won't think I'm disgusting
they won't think I'm trash you know and
then to go on stage and talk about it
have people laugh and then pay you is
the ultimate way to sort of heal all
that Shame about your thoughts and the
way it's like I can use this for
something you know and that's how I took
like my power back you know I was like
wait a second maybe all of the worst
things about me
will like help other people talking
about it will like help other people you
know and it forces me to tell the truth